right police here in new york city are
reportedly looking
for the drive-by gunman who may have
fired the wrong car killing a young boy
the shooting happened thursday as the
boy was sitting in the parked car with
relatives a vigil was held for him
yesterday
his death is the latest in a surge of
violence across the nation that has
picked up sharply in the last two years
nancy chen reports
bullet holes and shattered glass are
what's left behind after a 12-year-old
boy was killed when he and his family
were caught in the crossfire of a
shootout in brooklyn between people and
two other cars to have a young boy
shot and when you look at the video it's
horrific how it happened
and we're piecing together the pieces
the shooting is among the latest as
violence spikes in new york city so far
in 2022 crime is up nearly 45 percent
from last year
nationally homicide rates have risen by
an average of 37 percent in the biggest
cities so far this year in chicago
violent crime is up 36 percent in los
angeles 6 percent compared to the same
time last year u.s attorney general
merrick garland theorized why juveniles
appear to be committing more crimes the
leaders of the gangs don't want to face
punishment so they try to use a cutout
of in this particular example you're
talking about juveniles as crimes
continue to rise the past few days have
been deadly for law enforcement
pennsylvania police lieutenant william
lebo was killed on thursday while
responding to a domestic disturbance
call libo was just one month away from
retirement the surge in gun violence
prompted mayor adams last month to
relaunch a controversial nypd task force
to remove illegal guns off the streets
and add more officers on patrol for cbs
saturday morning nizi chen new york